foreign
speaking of
enjoying our spaces let's move on to the
minimalist home tour for this week this
is number 34 in our series and this is
from my home that notoriously Bex and I
live apart we used to live States apart
when we were she was living in Montana I
was living here but now we have a main
house and then there is a guest house or
a back house it's about 250 square feet
and this is the space where I live most
of the time the majority of the time and
it's rather Stark it's rather minimalist
I think it's sort of your aesthetic but
stripped down even slightly more part of
that is and I titled this photo balance
is the absence of excess now what does
excess for me is a lower threshold than
most people I'm not prescribing this to
anyone but this is what my home looks
like and it's changed relatively
recently I just sold my desk to
Professor Sean who's going to give me
some cash this afternoon hopefully
but we have this guest house and it has
two functions so like if Ryan comes up
to Ohio and wants to spend a couple
nights then great I have a guest house
you can sleep there there's a this
dining table here and I don't hang any
art on the walls but these sound panels
sort of function as art it's a rather
echoey space and I like to go in there
make phone calls or just work and to do
so having these sound panels to me
they're minimalist art in a way and they
look beautiful but it's aggressively
simple and I think the the details are
especially important when you get down
to this simple so like a simple Nelson
light that is there above the table and
these simple chairs from bow concept or
this tables from Design Within Reach but
then there's literally nothing else here
in in that picture the other side of the
room will go to the other
picture here is just a bed and an end
table and some lights right and some
natural light and that's quite literally
everything that's in that space except
there is if you're looking at this
picture it's on the the left of this
picture there's like a small kitchen or
a giant kitchenette I like to refer to
it as the mega kitchenette
but it has everything I need although I
would argue that the kitchen probably
has more than what I need in it because
I don't need a lot of excess storage and
and everything else so I'll be
simplifying that in the coming months
and years as well to make it closer to
my aesthetic but stripping down to the
essentials the bones become the beauty
of the space
yeah and I noticed that you lined up the
artwork with the top of the windowsill
yeah I assumed that was intentional yeah
very nice that's the kind of stuff that
I think about like I always look for the
architectural lines in a space and uh
try to make things relate to one another
and that creates a lot of balance yeah
yeah I well I think when we pay
attention to these details that's what I
love about your Instagram account and
your website you have a love for the
details yeah the the beauty is essential
but also finding the things that are
functional and making sure they're
beautiful so you're combining the form
and the function is so important quite
often here's what happens we try to
beautify our space with the things that
have no function at all that's why I
like the sound panels in a space like
this is because to me they're Beautiful
the clean lines yeah just real simple
but they also have a function they they
dampen the sound in that space yeah
however quite often what we'll do is we
will say all right I want so things that
are beautiful in my space here's some
artwork here are some plants or whatever
those things could be fine but then the
other things that are functional they'll
be ugly and and cumbersome and they're
kind of like oh they're they become
clutter visually yeah even if I still
use them every day I don't feel great
about using them because it it doesn't
match the things that make the room
beautiful yeah so I feel like there's my
background is in architecture and I feel
like there's this missed opportunity in
terms of levels of design you have urban
planning architecture interior design
and then that's kind of where people
stop but where where my mind continues
is the opportunity of the inside of a
drawer or a cabinet creating beautiful
beautiful arrangements and that's not
for everybody but that's where my joy
lies and you don't have to be rich to do
this I actually found minimalism when I
was unemployed
um a lot of it has to do with
Arrangement but then also selecting the
best possible thing that you can afford
you all talk about that a lot
um so that's why I love Brands like Muji
because they do have these beautiful
affordable things and I open up a drawer
and I'm like
so and then I look up in my wall and I'm
like yeah you know and why shouldn't
your home be a sanctuary like yes yeah I
often think about my storage spaces like
cabinets uh or above the laundry machine
or whatever it is that I wanna if
someone were to open it that someone
usually being me I want it to be similar
to a retail store not in the sense that
I have a large inventory of things but
everything's facing a particular way
because in retail Ryan and I worked in
retail for a really long time it's all
about the presentation if you want a
customer to feel welcomed in the store
you present things in a way that is
aesthetically pleasing oh yeah well why
don't I do that at home as well instead
of just cramming a bunch of things why
do we think our home isn't important
enough to take the time to do that when
it's the most important the most
important actually whenever someone
comes over to my space the Interiors of
the closet are part of the home tour I'm
like and look at our shared closet wow
and then everyone always goes I don't
wear half of my clothes I bet I could
get it down to that yes
that's exactly it and being in the 250
square foot space most of the time which
by the way I'm not prescribing this to
anyone Bex and I are extreme introverts
and we like having our distance which
makes our time together better and we've
been fortunate to be able to do that
where we have a little it's a garage
that's been converted into a 250 square
foot back House part of that is I don't
have the space to accumulate a bunch of
things and I still like to feel like
there's open space there right and so
having even fewer things gives me that
feeling of open space that freedom of
open space I feel Freer when I own fewer
things I feel lighter when I subtract
whenever I add I start to add anxiety I
start to add stress I add discontent I
add overwhelm and so by removing just a
few things getting down what is
essential and then what actually adds
value to my life
if it's not essential and it's not
value-adding then it's junk and I want
to get rid of it yeah minimum's mission
statement is make what is necessary
beautiful
so the necessary comes first and what
remains beautiful oh that is so good oh
man
it just came out of my mouth one day
when I was talking to somebody when I
started my business and they were like
you need to trademark that that's so
good yeah did you enjoy this Standalone
patreon highlight if so you can listen
to full episodes of the minimalist
private podcast available exclusively on
patreon visit patreon.com the
minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free